Speaker 1: Welcome to 2022 everybody. Great to be
back, and there is so much to talk about. It's an
election year. The election is getting going. It's
not going to take very long that I can assure you.
We have some good news to kick the year off with,
including specifically that radical Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene has been
banned permanently from Twitter. We will get
to that a little bit later in the day, but we
have to start with some words of caution. And
we have now heard from three military
retired military generals who are
sounding the alarm and saying in
2024, it's not just a Republican coup
that you have to worry about. You have to
worry about a military coup. One of the reasons
that Trump's coup attempt didn't work was that
he's very incompetent, of course, and he did not
have the military on his side. Now there's no
shortage of support for Trump in the military,
but he didn't have the generals on his side. And
what these three retired generals are pointing to
is the possibility that that could be different
in 2024. It doesn't necessarily have to be. Trump
could be a different Republican, and they are
now saying, you've got to be careful about
this. Very good NPR article. Retired general
warns the U.S. military could lead a coup
after the 2024 election and it says as the
anniversary and anniversary of the insurrection
at the Capitol approaches, three retired generals
are warning that another insurrection could occur
after the 2024 presidential election and the
military could instigate it. The generals,
Paul Eaton, Antonio Taguba and Steven Anderson,
made their case in a Washington Post op ed quote.
In short, we are chilled to our bones at
the thought of a coup succeeding next time
they have. These are highlights from a
conversation you can listen to, and I encourage
you to do so. How could a coup play out in 2024?
The real question is, does everybody understand
who the duly elected president is? If that is not
a clear cut understanding that can infect the rank
and file or at any level in the U.S. military?
And we saw it when 124 retired generals and
admirals signed a letter contesting the 2020
election. We're concerned about that. We're
interested in seeing mitigating measures applied
to make sure the military is better prepared.
This is a crucial point. We lucked out in a sense
that Trump and his cronies were too incompetent
and poorly organized to pull it off. And in
addition, if it ever got to the point of actually
getting the military involved. The officer
class and the generals in the military
weren't going for it, but there was this
letter signed by retired generals and high
ranking military officials that said We don't
believe the results. What happens if you see
that within the power structures, structures
of the military? Is it likely? No. I mean,
even they say, you know, when they're asked,
how worried are you on a scale from one to 10?
I see it as low probability, high impact. I
hesitate to put a number on it, but we need
to be prepared for it. In the military. We do a
lot of war gaming to ferret out what might happen.
You might have heard of the Transition Integrity
Project that occurred about six months before the
last election. We had four scenarios. And what
we did not play is a U.S. military compromised.
So we advocate that that particular scenario
be addressed in a future war game held well in
advance of 2024. And that is a very good idea. The
military has a ton of extremism in it. There are
self-study projects done. We've talked about some
of them about extremism and radicalization in the
military. There's a whole bunch of it right now.
It is not common, prevalent among the top brass.
It could change and imagine if it did. We know
that there are these boogaloo and proud boy types
in uniform talking openly about their involvement
in the Jan. six riots. It appears as though
they're going to be punished. Let's hope that
that happens. There were members of the military
that participated as individuals on January 6th,
and we know that this is a sort of feedback loop
when I've gotten emails from members of the
military who say David, sir are on base.
There's one news channel that's ever on TV,
and that channel is Fox News. And so when we,
you know, over the last two months, I've
been making a more concerted effort to say
this isn't just ha ha, look at these morons
in terms of the Jan. six stuff in terms of the
it was stolen by Joe Biden stuff. It's yes,
cartoonishly unhinged, and the world looks
at it and says, How could these idiots believe
this stuff? How, what, what has failed education,
media society? And the answer is yes, all
of the above. Of course, it all has failed,
but that doesn't mean we can just laugh it
off. And I've been taking it significantly more
seriously over the last couple of months. And this
these interviews from these three retired generals
should make all of us say, we can't just write
this off as kooks who could never get further
than they got in 2020. They could get further.
And one of the biggest components that would
make that a plausible possibility. Would be the
military actually really being on their side,
so we're going to continue talking about it? Worth
listening to the interview or at minimum, reading
the article from NPR will link to it in the
description for the YouTube clip for this story.